a baby boomer who's sitting there  thinking the Market's gonna be okay the  Market's not going to be okay for the  baby boomer baby boomer who is expecting  to retire at 64 years old who's 63 today  has to now work to 70 years old because  somebody didn't give him the right  counsel the part with giving counsel is  your counsel has to be given to whatever  situation you're currently in okay  that's the part about giving counsel  specifically when it comes down to  finances a a council like this that you  give to say that the housing market is  not going to crash it's not going to be  this it's not going to be that and then  the market does crash the real estate  does crash and you say rather than  saying this you say just in case this  happens be prepared in the following way